[Applaudissements]
le fou
le conseil de classe de matthieu
delormeau et oui alors les conseils de
classe est toujours actif mais sans la
fin de saison dont deux rien sendra sera
mais c'est vrai que là c'est le conseil
de classe toute l'année assez similaire
à celle rab alors je vous rappelle le
pot c'est le clash est une c'est une
séquence meetic de tpm paix si vous nous
avez rejoint depuis quelques semaines
sachez que chaque chroniqueur va donner
une note et une appréciation à matthieu
delormeau vous pourrez faire également
vous aussi bien entendu un sur twitter
puisque on attend vos commentaires sur
twitter données notamment qu avec le
hashtag tmp mathieu le conseil de classe
c'est aussi une séquence qui nous a fait
perdre énormément énormément énormément
énormément et on s'y attendait pas
parfois les gens se sont levés on dit je
quittais sur ben oui les gens à jour moi
je ne peux pas dire qu'ici je le
croisais je les croisais à jour après
conseil de classe
je vous jure que c'est vrai et c'était
la fin de l'émission et la personne ne
lui dit adieu aux randonnées guidées
vous le dis c'est là qu'on voit votre
courage parce que vous ne renoncez pas
vous conservez le conseil dès que non ça
me permet aux moineaux été le triste si
vous avez dit adieu ma vie dit juste
avant j'avais prévenu c'est son premier
conseil génie fait gaffe ça peut ruiner
on se dit des choses y stagnent inquiète
pas jacques huret pays manipulant calme
et bouge et ne parlons pas des absents
mais parlons plutôt mais de cette percée
sans moi j'aime bien que jeudi comme
témoin de ma démission et aurillac peur
moi je vis un petit conseil de cas ce
jeudi je reviens pas d'émission
si on fait un spectacle c'est sûr qu'on
viendra pas alors matthieu delormeau où
on va revenir sur l'année de matthieu
delormeau
ah oui en images mathieu en mots demain
la coiffure
no matter très bon comme ça ne coûte pas
trop maigri 6 si je refais les points
bas du filet et 7 points qui valent à
faire mal et regarde c'est parti pour le
conseil de classe de matthieu delormeau
un élève dissipé parfois très insolent
avec le professeur principal
tu apprendras tout petit peu à fermer ta
gueule quand vous n'êtes pas très très
cultivé
[Applaudissements]
vous avez été médecin légiste j'ai juste
fait ce que vous n'avez pas fait mon
chéri des études
mathieu un élève qui malgré des
interventions pas toujours très
pertinentes s'aime beaucoup mais genre
beaucoup beaucoup
mathieu c'est lui qui dira tnt le
vendredi 13 annette je ne vais jamais
dans les cinémas public parce que ça
crée des émeutes où sofia et malgré son
visage d'ange posée sur un corps de gogo
dancer mathieu est aussi capable de se
fâcher tout rouge
désolé tant pis s'il me faire et insulté
je le redis est encore plus fort potiche
une fille comme ça je ne sais vraiment
humiliée toutes les femmes elle peut
faire la vérité toi tu truc est aisée
mais même s'il a longtemps été désigné
comme le fayot est pris en grippe par
les autres élèves
mathieu sait se montrer bon camarade
dans l'ensemble celui qui m'a tendu la
main comme dans la rue et qu'une valise
dans ma voiture et je ne savais pas où
dormir
et c'est peut-être la première fois que
je vais pouvoir lui lui rendre ce qu'il
m'avait donné ce jour là autrement que
par un merci je te laisse partir côté
danse en revanche c'est un sans faute
voilà enfin une matière où mathieu
briller
alors quelle note pour mathieu
on savait qu'on nous demande très
souvent votre avis il ya une jauge en
battu mathieu enfin les mollahs ya une
chose qui va bouger et vous nous dites
si vous avez envie de revoir mathieu
mais non mais alors à l'antenne et vous
allez vous dire si vous avez envie que
mathieu soit là l'année prochaine ou pas
oui bien sûr nous on a envie et moi nous
dit vous aussi ça sera pareil pour tout
âge si les gens ne parviendra pas où il
viendra quand même écouter après on en
discute mais je ne vois pas les gens ne
pas vouloir nous penser n'a pas d'ordre
fallait pas trop de risques quand même
ça va et l'élection
non la gagne mais on a eu déjà ces deux
mauvaises sur concerné c'est bon allez
les chéris on y va je vais démarrer ce
conseil de classe et j'attends
d'ailleurs d'avoir l'avis de doc gynéco
c'est son premier conseil d'état si en
tant que professeur aujourd'hui aussi je
vais demander l'avis allez on va
démarrer par quelqu'un tu m'as tu dis
voilà fait pas de vague mais qu'on aime
et qui normalement n'est pas méchante
ses valises à eau très bien mairie elle
va lire est ce que vous aimez mathieu
fruits et pas tellement pas ce jeu
cartonne le vendredi sa case elle
rentrait très mal les jeunes contre
toute attente voyez ce petit bonhomme là
est absolument insupportable
voilà il élira l' il se prend pour une
diva
il croit qu'il est le centre du monde
que son nombril intéresse la terre
entière il la ramène tout le temps mais
c'est vrai c'est en tout cas où ici les
gens nous rejoignent certitude qu'on
parle de lui et il est même persuadé
qu'il coanime tpm paix avec vous c'est
le comble mais malgré tout ça et ça
m'arrache de le dire vraiment
il est drôle il a un avis sur tout même
quand c'est un avis qui est absolument
contraire à l'ensemble de ses camarades
et t il y va à fond il ne se dédit pas
il a des cojones c'est aurélien des
cojones et mouiller la chemise
il est il est là pour faire le show et
il le fait lors il peut parfois nous
irriter mais il fait le show et pour
tout ça et je peux vous dire que ça
m'arrache un joli donne à fond noté
mathieu aussi bien sûr si vous allez on
va s'gêner avec raymond qui vient de
mourir a alors moi je vais je vais voilà
ce sont mathieu je vais parler
franchement je vais te parler
franchement pour moi y'a 2 mathieu on
était franchement il ya deux mathieu
mathieu ça fait ça fait six mois que je
suis là j'ai vu mathieu télé homme de
télé quand il fait des ducks qui produit
des docks pour ces huit ça cartonne
quand il à l'antenne ça cartonne
toujours quand il s'agit de mener sa
troupe
ça cartonne c'est très bien le soir
quand il est là i dont 6 féminines
fublaines farmer et jette par terre
quand cyril un peu moins bien c'est toi
qui viens parfois qui relance le truc
avec jean mi y'a pas de souci là-dessus
merci à notre problème avec le 2e
mathieu ah ouais le 2e mathieu lui qu'on
absolue collectionnables le connard vous
le connaissez aussi 2e mathieu quand la
lumière à 7 ans on sait pas si tu joue
un rôle aussi été comme ça dans la vie
le mathieu autun le mathieu qui
m'appelle babou je m'appelle pas booth
mais c'est pas grave le mathieu et tu
peux pas croisé capitain ce soir
preneurs de sons une maquilleuse un
caméraman un maître de la prod qui te
regarde droit dans les yeux et qui te
dis mais de leurs maux il fait exprès
voulait vraiment comme ça alors
justement dans ce que vous dites une
grande surprise tout à l'heure car y
aura un représentant des techniciens de
la production qu'il viendra donner sa
note à 22 langues est ce représentant
c'est une fille elle était folle odyssée
soria
tu vas me voilà donc une amie pour
toutes ces raisons et ta carrière je te
mets un beauty ce penalty sérieux cette
divine
c'est ce soir en blanc le blanc pour un
magnifique mais je suis avec cet outil
d'une crèche comme ça c'est la première
fois qu'ils me pas et puis un en excès
[Rires]
ses points faibles
si on les connaît j'en ai de ses
aventures sexuelles et là il hurlé
soucier cela j'ai fait l'amour avec un
cyril et ceci toujours en dessous de la
ceinture
voilà ça franchement perso j'en ai fonce
droit dans les loges quoi comment les
moins forts les points forts moi j'adore
je t'adore je l'avais déjà dit l'année
dernière tu es vraiment tu me fait rien
tout le temps même lorsque tu es con tu
me fais rien surtout quand tu es content
d'ailleurs battu et torturé un sens de
la répartie coutume apple oui excuse moi
je donne envie
toi tu m'appelles ce que je suis en
clientèle l'accusé a mis 12
il est pas très attendu j'espère retrait
pour les banques de quoi aider par leurs
restes d'os de may cry quelque chose je
ne comprends rien de ce qu'il dit il va
monter un truc très marqué sur sa folle
sur la tête de ma mère on a l'impression
d'être dans une énigme de poids moyens
thomas do demain dos de cabillaud qu'ils
ont battus je sais pas ce qu'il a dit je
connaissais pas on attend ce monde ça
nous casse avec impatience et au delà
donc d'accord je dois beaucoup trop
réfléchi journée avec toi champions si
oui alors et je résume à mathieu à ça
une extrême sensibilité qui me touche
beaucoup et c'est de ça que j'y mets un
beau c'est johnny body alors mathieu
merci
c'est quelqu'un de sensible tu pourras
et choses à coeur dans la vie or
émission ce peut être une qualité si ces
humbles et veux tu prends trop les
choses à coeur tu étais un petit peu
capricieux donc offert intentions pour
ça pour les côtés positifs tuer
quelqu'un de marrant tu nous fais tout
ce qui fait tous les jours un tas d'or
tous est vraiment sincèrement enfin moi
je le thème sincèrement et cadets et
j'adore tes analyses je suis souvent
d'accord avec toi
[Rires]
un des miens c'est à dire que le 5 mai
j'appelle mon idée bosque mais si je
veux pas baisser mois concerne nous
allons si je ne vais pas baisser alors
que très drôle ainsi mamie des foires
contre nous souvent contre nous
tu es très intelligent tu es
délicieusement politiquement incorrect
et des fois ça m'arrange pour un jeu
physiquement ça ne faut pas exagérer non
plus très charmant quand tu veux tu veux
pas souvent et on passe maintenant aux
points faibles sont les points faibles
lecture an dans une pièce c'est vrai que
ça bouffe l'oxygène de tout le monde
notamment pour ceux qui savent pas
complètement réagir le carélien quand je
les recevrai et surtout de draguer cyril
la contrée chance de gravir le mont
blanc accosté que de tout faire quand en
2004 est de couper les cheveux c'est à
moi qui pense oui mais c'est nous qui
regardons bravo voilà répond tout ça
alors bref tout est là j'ai envie de te
frapper quand tu n'es sans mon siège
change 53 les gens vivent vraiment de
tête anglais et lorsque conséquente est
pas là tu nous manques
pour tout ça je te mets à 13 min au même
comment quand c'est l'essentiel a déjà
tapé l'envers ça m'agace perdait il
verde mathieu vous avez une énorme
qualité c'est la constance au vous avez
été au fil des saisons très mauvais ici
à la mi-temps d'un désastre humain et
cette régularité dans l'échec ça vous
honore
et vous savez mathieu contrairement à ce
que vous pensez je suis capable de
changer d'opinion sur vous dernièrement
vous avez vraiment fait très bonne
émission et ya deux semaines quand vous
étiez chez vous gros problème
franchement que vous avez tout le monde
le sait c'est votre ego vous avez un ego
surdimensionné phone je dis ça c'est
sacrificielle je sais que tous vos fans
vont me détester sa rame faire au moins
trois ou quatre et demi de plus flou la
q2 dit non alors ce malade qui m'a
insulté moi mais mes fans français
international saviez vous le savez la
déroulant d'énergie pour les savait ça
revient alors soit notre point faible je
vais aller vite parce que sinon sa
frappe raser les points forts on vous a
rimé touche pas à mon poste arrive
rarement
c'est une cata ce n'est quand même car
elle allie ferme le coup c'est dire non
non non non franchement mathieu pour
[ __ ] d'énormes point de satisfaction
pour moi c'est la note
cette note je le concède cirilli faut
pas m'en vouloir
j'ai cédé à l'amitié nouvelle qui me lie
à mathieu à recevoir en dehors on
s'appelle way et comme j'ai obtenu de la
production l'accord incroyable de poire
mais des 2000 points
je voulais vraiment mis la note de
l'amitié 0.5
benjamin castaldi mathieu mais je vais
fait bref c'est vrai que tu excellent
merci j'étais un homme était content
enfin coûte cher qu'un sexe c'est
l'oeuvre d'art mouillé ou pas les
maîtres et huile ardoise donc mathieu tu
excellent tu le sais oui mais c'est vrai
tu es un vrai connard
mais je le sais aussi sévère donc tu es
drôle je suis rapide est ton point
faible c'est que au final
ttt mais tu es méchant en fait t'es un
mauvais camarade donc les bêtes et
méchantes et comme relaté comme
hara-kiri et tueries souvent aux dépens
des autres souvent avec les en plus
faible que toi jamais tu t'attaques à
des gens forts puissants super dray
aurait pu être une bonne note
donc je te mets je te mets 1 4
[Applaudissements]
entre animateurs les notes déjà donné
car il manque la note de jean michel mr
et de doc gynéco on terminera par la
note de doc gynéco bien sûr est ce qu'on
peut voir les notes des chroniqueurs qui
ont déjà donné les cronje qui ont voilà
qui ont déjà donné en notes merci en
régie là je l'aurais mis un truc dans la
tête
votre talent la note de jean michel mr
et l'appréciation du juge rappelle que
c'est un des meilleurs amis de mathieu
du tout on le retourne très bien si
c'est mon meilleur ami mais j'ai
suffisamment de son ce professionnel
pour être honnête quand je donne des
notes
évidemment je vais pas chaque grand cas
du grand suspense ma note jamie d'ici à
trois ans j'ai mis 10 l'année dernière
je mettrais de 10 cette année évidemment
mieux pour moi mathieu quelqu'un de dako
parade certes il a peut-être des
problèmes d'ego mais le lego est souvent
de et souvent raccords et hauts talons
la légende on goûte à londres un couple
un problème d'ego aussi voilà ça arrive
en tout cas elle s'embrouille avec des
personnes mais gruissan bruit parce que
toujours sincères et n'est jamais prêt à
piétiner ses convictions voilà pour
faire plaisir à tel ou tel nom quand on
a quelque chose à dire il le dit voilà
mais à côté de ça je mais c'est
quelqu'un c'est comme dalida quand il
arrive sur scène tout le monde c'est par
là qu'il arrive sa lumière s'allume et
pas lui c'est du coup il fait chaud et
les spectacles il a le sens du time ni
le sens de la répartie il est très drôle
ou pas c'est bon pour faire danser par
les élèves je le dis voilà les mois
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
contente en plus il perd tout sens
montreux temmar oui c'est mon côté je me
suis montrée theman6 j'en vois un petit
peu le niveau qu'on assiste note ça
c'était sa note me sa note sur son
appréciation
je voulais donner dès maintenant j'aime
du bund avance prestation du professeur
docteur gerald tu peux du cul francis
entendu ça comme dalida et s'allume avec
la lumière fédéral espère que sa part
comme claude françois d'objets déco
alors mathieu alors oui je t'ai donné la
connais la mienne je sais qu'il s'est
déjà bien sûr
alors allez alors mathieu j'étais donné
6 6 sur 20 sur 10 tu veut repasser
demain juste que tu divisent par deux ou
trois patients des démissions des 6 sur
20 ça fait 3 sur 10 pour faire gagner
des points
qu'est ce que tu voulais lui m six sur
dix n'ont même pas de 6 sur 20 c'est sûr
qu'au niveau de la mémoire toi
on est venu memory non mais sans y mêler
sans doute ici c'est lors d'un nom mais
après j'ai dit sur des bateaux allant
même à 12,48 déjà tous peints sur quatre
critères d'appréciation moi je t'avais
donné 6 c sur nice alors été pour voir
si tu méritais 3 au 6 mai 3
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai plus gros je me suis cachée sous la
pression et je verrai en fonction ce que
tu monsieur taylor fois que ça arrive tu
l'as cannes a des qualités vraiment
exceptionnel il apporte quelque chose
que j de qui tu parles de mathieu
d'accord de tout le monde dans
l'émission de mathieu apporte quelque
chose que rares sont ceux parmi nous qui
avons la capacité d'avoir faim les tue
50 à léonie ce qu'apporte mathieu major
avec ce qui l'amène ce que vous ce que
vous réfutez que vous n'aimez pas j'aime
beaucoup jamais ne croit ni avec quad et
des maquereaux dans le peu de vulgarité
[Applaudissements]
ce que lui ou bien le jeu mais 3-3 je
crois alors c'est ça qui voulaient bien
sûr que oui c'est ça te dérange qui veut
de pécho c'est pas mignon et willard
jamais la seule phrase jamais de la
vulgarité
non alors à l'état mais alors il dit
j'ai pas dit ça m'a dit ça mais ce qu'il
vient de dire tout cas tu vas être très
utile dans les conseils de jeu le 100g
le pis pour ça on va rentrer la
représentante de la production une super
série
soraya
[Applaudissements]
elle est finie ce radar est pas à ses
débuts alors son regard on va te dira lé
été choisi pour représenter la
prévention devrait présenter lundi je
fais partie la bonne idée cette année
par ma personne pas votre à la toque
genre de boussois ans mercy alors que
mathieu il a fait un peu d'effort par
rapport à l'année dernière
il est bon il s'est toujours pas nos
prénoms je suis désolé on rails or mais
ouais mais qu'en même temps comme étant
je t'ai fait la gueule pendant trois
mois mais qu'il ne pouvait pas des
chevaux du coupé que le leader que la
star oui mais alors ça t'empêche pas
dire bonjour comment allez vous s'il
vous plaît donc tu veux la dart le jeu
dans l'appréciation l'appréciation d'un
peu mieux fait
euh tu vois quand même ou pas mais mieux
que l'année dernière
alors c'est mieux que l'année dernière
donc il fait des projets suis pas ton
ami comme tu as dit on a trop gros mytho
mane
mais voilà m'étonnera noël dans le 400 m
c'est mon ami a déjà travaillé avec ed à
nouna des céline dion des justin bieber
ça ou mariah carey c'est vrai que je
reviens je reviens de cannes je traque
des stars internationaux a donc tout ce
[Rires]
sur quoi je taille et / ou foot aux
petites gens semblent pas au
rassemblement succès 1-3 mais tu fais
des passes que tu m'aimes encore des
bijoux les lois
[Applaudissements]
elle a dû avec efficacité dans l'inconnu
avec cabriolet non c'est vrai c'est
naturel passé avec mathieu et le soir à
une couche et balayez devant la caravane
sera ya derrière
ah bah merci chaud sous ce statut n'a
mis à part de voir la note du public
mathieu dis nous ce que tu as ressenti
cette année mon chéri à écoute j'ai
compris pourquoi
mon ami je crois qu'il me le rend bien
ça me touche justin bieber avait arrêté
sa son concert elle sa tournée un petit
peu internationale avant la fin c'est à
dire que est comme moi ils donnent
beaucoup comme lui je donne beaucoup et
parfois le rythme est effréné et est
difficile parce que c'est vrai que jouer
avec vous c'est renvoyé la balle à nadal
et si on n'est pas à 100%
là forcément se prend à ce match donc
c'est vrai que et le niveau de la
pression est encore plus rapide chaque
année parce que les gens sont rodés
parce que beinheim après neuf ans a
compris l'émission parce que donc c'est
une émission qui était difficile à faire
et c'est vrai que le rythme et était
cette année peut-être plus difficile
pour moi de l'année dernière en tout cas
ouais on s'est bien marré cette année
non franchement elle essaie on sait on
s'est régalé on va voir la note du
public donc les chroniqueurs 5,65
les twittos 6,43 bien
wayans jr supervision en estonie
[Applaudissements]